hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled sars cov2
quality control for molecular and
serology
assays i'm susie valdez of labyrinths
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by bio rad laboratories
i'd like to invite everyone to
participate by submitting your questions
during this presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and click send
any questions we don't answer during the
webinar will be captured and responded
through the q a list that will be posted
next week in the event
resources box which is located in the
ask a question box
you'll also be able to download these
presentation handouts from this event
resource box once the webinar
is available on demand if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
simply click on the concerns button ask
a question box and we will address
those issues as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process
to obtain those credits so let's get
started
today's webinar on quality control for
sars code v2
testing consists of two presentations
and a q
a session at the end the first
presentation will focus on
quality control for molecular testing i
now present today's first speaker dr
dwayne newton dr newton is the director
of the clinical microbiology laboratory
as well as associate
director of the division of clinical
pathology both in the department of
pathology
at michigan medicine in ann harbour
michigan usa
his research interests lie in the
development of molecular assays for the
diagnosis
and management of infectious diseases
for a complete biography of dr newton
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr newton welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
thank you so much susie and thank you
everyone for
joining us today my talk is entitled
molecular qc
for qualitative sars coe2 testing you
can observe a lot
just by watching so we'll get into some
of these little quotes
and their origins here as we get going
on the talk
so first off i'd like to share some
disclosures
outside activities i'm involved in i
serve as a consultant part-time
with navidx i'm on the scientific
advisory board for two companies quantum
matrix
and bio-rad and i'll actually be joining
navidx as a full-time consultant
in september i'll be leaving the
university of michigan
a couple of objectives today goals for
you and the audience which i hope you'll
be able to
[Music]
take from the presentation is to be able
to describe
some approaches for sars cov2 molecular
testing
in the quality control standpoint and
how that
can be used to monitor the entire
testing process
as well as look at some optimal
practices and maybe idealize
ideal characteristics of quality control
material that you could use
in your assays
now first we have a lot of different
directions that we can go for qc
but we might not might not actually know
exactly the direction that we need to go
unfortunately we have
a lot of guidance that can help us
maybe a little more guidance than yogi
berra the baseball great
and sometimes trying to be baseball
philosopher
might say if you don't know where you're
going you'll end up someplace else well
we don't want to end up someplace else
we want to end up
in a place where we're performing uh
good quality control
and we're also we have a robust qc
or qa program and because of the
guidance that we have
in our labs in particular from
checklists like uh that's available from
the
college of american mythologists that
helps point us down the right road and
keep us on the right path
so i'll share with you a couple of items
that i'm sure most of us are familiar
with
but form the basis for how we perform qc
in our laboratories and you can see in
this item
the cap states that qc should be run at
least daily
or more frequently depending on what the
manufacturer's package insert says and
that can be impacted that that frequency
can be impacted
by any changes that occur and so if
there's a potential for change
if there's a potential for variability
in your assay then
there's uh the desire is to do testing
more frequently to do qc
testing more frequently and so any
changes of
critical reagents any preventative
maintenance that occurs
are components that are critical for
performance of the test
any type of change like that you should
do
qc again to make sure that everything's
operating properly
as far as the types of controls to use
if you're performing a quantitative test
which we're not really going to get into
at all today but cap gives guidance on
qc for quantitative tests and that
should include a negative control low
positive and a high positive control
for us really in today's discussion
with qualitative tests a positive and
negative control should be run at least
daily
but i'll show you some examples of these
types of controls
both those that are
included within manufacturer's kits as
well as some external controls that
potentially could be used for
qc and laboratory develop tests and
you'll see that
even though they are a positive or
negative control their characteristics
are can be very different and we'll talk
about some of the reasons
why and maybe some of the attributes
that you would look for
in an ideal control but ultimately
the controls that you use must assess
the adequacy of your extraction
your amplification and detection
processes and so it needs to go through
the entire testing process to be
appropriately used
so as i just mentioned there are
controls that are available from the
manufacturer that are included in kits
and there are also controls that are
available from
third parties that can be used as
external control material
uh but you know which of these should we
be using and when should we be using
them and so
sometimes when we look at this there's
lots of different options and
potentially forks in the road
and as mr barrow says when you come to a
fork in the road take it
and in this case we're going to be using
both of them or could be using both of
them and so
how might that look and what does that
look like
one of the challenges though especially
with sars controls
is that we need to understand
um a little bit of the complexity of the
virus itself
to know how these controls are
configured and how they might be used
so i'm going to spend just a brief
period discussing the genomic structure
of sars
of the sarsko v2 virus and talk about
the genes
and some of the proteins that they
encode
and that'll be important for both an
understanding of the
molecular controls as well as some of
the control material that dr thiel will
talk about in her presentation
so the genomic structure is pretty
simple
it's about 30 000 bases the virus is a
single stranded rna virus
that is an envelope virus
so the first open reading frame contains
some proteases that are involved in
post-translational modification of the
viral protein so
open reading frame 1a there's also
open reading frame 1b that contains the
genes for the rna-dependent
rna polymerase or nsp12 as well as a
helicase enzyme
nsp13 and then there are structural
proteins
that are involved in
creating those protein structures that
are involved in the
uh both the envelope as well as um
with the matrix um uh
the nucleocapsid proteins associated
with nucleic acid so
the spike gene encodes the spike protein
that forms
those characteristic coronavirus crown
like spikes
there's envelope gene for envelope
proteins
membrane proteins and nucleocapsid
proteins
so again about 30 000 bases
the assays that and the control material
that i'm going to describe
are controls that i have used and
have been used in our laboratory in the
assays that we have in production in our
laboratory
and are meant to be just an example of
the the
kinds of variability and the approaches
that manufacturers have taken
it's not an exhaustive list it doesn't
represent all the different options that
are available but are the ones that i
can speak to because of our experience
the first asset i'm going to talk about
is the abbott m2000 assay and and this
is a platform that we are using for high
throughput
testing primarily of asymptomatic
patients asymptomatic screening in pre
in the pre-procedural
arena the assay targets for this test
are the it's a dual target rna-dependent
rna polymerase
as well as n-gene that are the sars cov2
targets and then it also includes an
internal control sequence that
is uh proprietary but as a
plant pumpkin seed gene that should not
be present in any human specimens but
gets spiked into
all the specimens that are extracted
it's in the lysis buffer that comes with
the
system and it is carried through from
extraction through amplification and
detection and
it serves to show that the extraction
process works the amplification and
detection process works
so as reported out for every specimen
within the assay it has positive control
and negative control material the
positive control material is
a recombinant synbus virus that contains
stars cov2 sequences that are
specifically targeted by the assay so it
includes the
rdrp gene as well as the n gene
that virus is replication defective and
heat inactivated so it's not infectious
but it has
a structure that's very similar to what
a a routine virus would be
look would appear in a clinical specimen
the negative control is just buffer
that's essay buffer
um but that's not really like um i think
one of the downsides in this is that
it's not
like sample matrix and so i think one of
the themes that
i'd like to try to articulate through
this is
the types of controls and the matrix c's
that are used in them
should in an ideal situation would mimic
as closely as possible what you would
expect to see in a clinical sample
and and that would true would be
uh give you a true sense of how your
assay is performing
the other uh mainstay in our laboratory
for
sars cov2 testing is a diastore and
simplexa test
this platform we are primarily using
for testing of symptomatic patients in
our emergency department
and inpatient populations this essay
also is a multiplex targeted assay um
targeting sequences in the open reading
frame one a
and b as well as the spike gene
it also has an internal control sequence
that is proprietary
the nice thing about this assay is that
it doesn't require any extraction you
put your sample
directly into the disk and it uses heat
to
lyse the sample and release the nucleic
acid and then that asp
the nucleic acid is amplified and
detected
that rna internal control sequence is
um is part of the master mix that's
included in the
in the assay and so we'll go through the
that entire testing process
as well the positive controls are a
little bit different
these are just synthetic gene fragments
of the targets of the assay
placed in universal transport media so
it's not
like the abbott assay that's structured
like a virus
but just constitutes the the target that
the assay is trying to detect
and the no template control or negative
control that's used in this test
is uh is viral transport media that you
have in your laboratory
so that's more like what we would see in
a clinical specimen because that's how
the samples are getting to us
but the positive control is is a little
different than what we would expect to
see
a viral structure taking in a clinical
sample
so those are the examples of the assays
that we use in our lab
are two of the assays that we use in our
lab and the controls that are available
i'm going to go through some um
what we're what i'd like to refer to as
external controls or third-party
controls that could be used in tests
and have a variety of different use
cases which i'll i'll share with you
in a few slides but there are a variety
of manufacturers that have developed
control material that can be used in
stars cov2 testing
they all have different characteristics
so the two that
are listed here are similar and they
both originate from
cultures of virus and the one from
zeptometrics
is actually heat inactivated fluid from
the viral culture
so those virus was cultivated
in vitro and the culture of supernatant
was taken
and heat inactivated and that's where
the purifier that's where the
high concentrations of virus are present
the
virus was actually isolated from a
patient
in washington state who returned from
china one of the
original patients that were identified
in the united states
and um that virus has
been deposited into a
repository and they've provided this
specific virus that that was derived
from
the matrix that it comes in is tissue
culture media which is
similar to what a specimen would be
received in
again this is live virus the challenge
with this is we don't know
from lots a lot how much we're getting
because the tighter the amount of
viruses present
is a lot specific the other challenge
with this is that
the um the quantity of virus is
provided in tissue culture infective
doses
50 tcid 50 as opposed to
copies per ml which we're more familiar
with
in molecular diagnostics and so it's
it's difficult to make a correlation
between
the amount of virus that's present and
how much
and how that translates into a molecular
assay
the bei product is similar it was
derived from culture
but that actually extracted the rna
and that is provided in
tris eta buffer the biggest challenge
with
rna extract is that that rna is very
fragile and can be
um easily degraded by rnases that are in
the environment or in other
materials that are used in the test and
so um
there were challenges we experience
challenges when we use
this and freeze thaw and stability over
time and dilutions
that the rna would degrade because it
wasn't stabilized
another product that was available that
we evaluated or
utilized in our development process was
the circare
acuplex positive reference material
this is also that's very similar and may
be exactly what
abbott is using for their positive
control but this is
symbus virus background that's
replication defective
and heat treated and within that
viruses synthetic
genomic information reflected here in
this list so there are different parts
of the
open reading frame rdrp genes the s gene
e gene and
n gene that are designed to be
detectable in a variety of assays
in the back are the negative reference
material as they describe it
is symbis virus with a human rna's p
gene and that is a great
negative reference material or negative
control
because there are several assays that
have been developed
that use human rnasp
as a target for their internal control
to show that you actually had a specimen
in this in the sample and
amplification of that um shows that
there was clinical material present
and so that's a nice control to mimic
what
we would see in a clinical sample
again these are provided in viral
transport media which are
are um similar to how a sample would be
received the challenger the limitation
with this product is that
uh it's relatively low copy number and
so that makes it difficult to use for
limited detection assays or dilution
series where you want to have a broader
range of concentrations
of target
another product which is available from
exact diagnostics
is um synthetic rna
transcripts at a very high concentration
but with large portions of all the genes
listed here and so they're
covering a lot of the genome and
as far as i can tell all the assays that
are present can be we'll have targets
that
can be detected using this control the
high concentration makes it very easy to
get a broad range of dilutions
and the concentration has been
accurately quantified using droplet
digital
pcr and so the number that you get is
very very precise it also contains in
the background human genomic dna and as
i mentioned before there
are many assays that target
rna's p gene and human genome
as a as an internal control and so by
including that
genomic dna you allow for that to be
detected as well by the same
control material and it also
provides some background um that is very
similar to what we would expect to see
in a clinical specimen that you'd have
target rna as well as human genomic dna
present in that specimen so that um
is more like a true patient sample
the the biggest limitation that we saw
early on was that the the fact that
these were rna transcripts
again made them susceptible to
degradation and so
one of the things that helps prevent
that from happening is actually making
the dilutions of this
in the negative control buffer because
the buffer has
rnase inhibiting properties and so it
maintains and improves the stability of
that
of that material
lastly one of the controls that are
widely available and was available very
early on was from
integrated dna technologies and these
control materials were
simply plasmids containing
some of the sars cov2 genes
and so the plasmids from
idt have the entire nuclear capsid
gene and if you recall from the cdc
assay
the original cdcsa targeted the
n1 and n2 genes of the nucleic acid
which are included in that material
it also came in very very high
concentration that
hundreds of thousands of copies per
microliter and so that
that material could last a long time
their negative control
was again sequences of the rna's p
gene which that human rnasp which is the
target
of the cdc assay and some other
assays that have been made available
but these again these were easy to make
um
came out very early in
the response but really don't
resemble what we would expect to see in
a true patient
specimen and so it's not an ideal
type of control as we'll get to
in a little bit so i'll talk
briefly in the last couple of slides
about the value of external controls and
their
use cases this can be a little
challenging sometimes we have to put our
heads
wrap our heads around some of these
thoughts and yogi berra had a tough time
doing math and articulated
as 90 of this game or this effort that
we're trying to
to make is half mental but if we
can sort it out uh and maybe go through
in step wise fashion
we can um get the other half that's not
so mental
what can we use and how do we use the
different materials that are available
there's a lot of different options
from the controls and kits the other
commercial controls
commercial panels i really would think
of more
and quantitative panels that have
different members that
are quantified to a very precise level
and those are really more appropriate
for
quantitative assays and so
in situations where you're actually
looking at leaning trying to get
linearity or doing calibrations
that's how that's what i would refer to
as a commercial panel
you could use patient samples for a lot
of these efforts culture material
but primarily what we're dealing with is
on the left side the kit controls and
other commercial controls they have they
have value
and a lot of processes
not only from
the validation or verification but also
depending on whether it's a
fda or eua authorized kit
those controls would come with the kit
if you're doing a laboratory develop
test you could potentially utilize
these external control materials for
that
daily qc
so just to summarize the information
that was on that last slide
these external control material can be
used
in verification of
fda approved cleared products validation
of laboratory develop tests but as i
said at the beginning when you have
a lot to lot changes um
it you could use your kit controls or
you could use
external control material from one of
these manufacturers like in the last few
slides
one of the important things to consider
is to use external control materials
on a regular basis as an independent
monitor to monitor across
the lots to monitor across changes in
the instruments or
or prevent a maintenance and so you know
when
our our kit lots
change we might compare one lot to the
other
but how does that compare to lots over
time and if you have
a very stable external control material
that has a very long
out date that you potentially could run
across lots for months
that might give you a better indication
that there are changes happening to your
to your testing that you might not
might not pick up by just doing a lot to
lock comparisons
these commercially available products
are often much more stable than
some of the other options that we might
make ourselves like
you know taking pool taking patient
samples and pool that pulling them
and making aliquots and freezing them
which is a lot of work
much more work when we have to create
them our own
and if i if designed ideally
they can really these external controls
can
do just as good of a job as mimicking uh
real clinical samples as ones that we
would make ourselves
and so if think about you know with all
this information
what would be the ideal control i think
i've listed a few characteristics i i
want them to be
um as close to being a real virus or
mimicking a real virus or
pathogen as possible um so that
it structurally it resembles the
pathogen that you're trying to detect
and that it has the target information
that
is broad enough that it could
potentially be used with any
manufacturer's assays one of the
problems with the care assay i listed
all
you know the gene targets that was in
there um
it can't be it couldn't actually be used
with the dsorin test because the
the targets in the open reading frame
that it
has in its um in the synthetic virus
do not overlap the sequences that are
targeted
by the dsorin test so that was one of
the limitations for there and so
the control material needs to be robust
enough to have
to be applicable on all these different
platforms i'd like to see you know high
concentrations or high tiders that are
precisely quantified so that you can do
large dilution studies and look at
limits of detection and be able to
compare across platforms that might have
different
uh lods we want them to be stable to
freeze thaw because
a lot of times when we're doing these
tests you can't do them all in the same
day and so you'd like to make your
pollutions and freeze them so that
they're
it's from the same dilution series i'd
like to see
genomic dna background and more of these
controls
that helps with serving as a control for
some of the assays that target
um human genes but also because that
is how our patient samples should
ideally be they should have human dna in
them and
and that can impact how our acid
perform i'd like them to have a matrix
which mimics real
the real specimens that we're receiving
and
as we stated at the beginning it
controls for the total testing process
from
extraction to detection
so with that i'll finish my part of the
presentation
but the game's not over because the very
talented agent
dr thiel will be taking over
and sharing her perspectives on
qc for serology testing
thank you dr newton for that informative
presentation on molecular qc for
qualitative sars
cov2 testing turning our focus now to
quality control for serology
testing i now present today's second
speaker
dr ellie thiel dr thiel is a director of
the infectious diseases serology
laboratory at mayo clinic an associate
professor of laboratory medicine and
pathology
at mayo clinic college of medicine in
rochester minnesota
usa dr thiel oversees the development
and evaluation of serologic
methods at mayo clinic and has evaluated
over
15 different serologic tests for
detection of antibodies
to sars code v2 over the past
last few months for complete biography
of dr thiel
please visit the biography tab at the
top of the screen
dr thiel welcome you may now begin your
presentation
great well thank you dr newton for the
informative
talk on molecular testing for stars kobe
2 and
thank you susie for the introduction so
for the second part of this webinar
i'll talk about quality control
considerations for high throughput
qualitative serologic tests for stars
cov2 that currently have
emergency use authorization so before
delving in these are my disclosures
and for the learning objectives they're
listed here and hopefully
by the end similar to what dr newton
mentioned you'll be able to take away a
couple
of kind of optimal quality control
practices for serologic testing in your
lab
so when it comes to stars kovi
sterologic
assays 39 currently have eua
which about 20 or so are what i would
consider high
throughput serologic assays and
important to keep in mind is that these
are all
quite varied in their design including
their format so we have rapid lateral
flow assays
uh batch testing enzyme linked
immunosorbent assays or elisa's
and then your more continuous load
chemiluminescent based assays
these specimen types that have been
validated also differ
most are validated for serum or plasma
although there is now one
site specific lab that can use dried
blood spot extracts
the type of antibody that
is detected also varies between these
assays be it igm
or igg or total antibodies without
differentiation
the sars cov2 protein or antigen that's
used to capture these antibodies
also varies some assays use recombinant
as subunit 1 or subunit 2
antigens or recombinant receptor binding
domain
regions from the spike protein and then
other assays use a recombinant form of
the nucleocapsid protein
and then finally while the vast majority
of eua assays are qualitative in nature
there is now one semi-quantitative assay
that has received e-way
so overall though the point here is that
these variables should be kept in mind
when considering what type of control
you
will be using for your assay and
for tests specifically that don't have
control materials provided in the kit
itself
so this is just a high level table
summarizing all of those variables that
i just mentioned for the high throughput
assays in particular and you can see
that the majority of them
at this point are actually
chemiluminescent based
which unlike for the elisa-based methods
most of these typically do not come with
their own
internal kit control instead for these
assays the laboratory either has to
create
or purchase and validate their controls
separately
and so while most of the manufacturers
of these assays do provide
external qc material for purchase
separately
there are also now at least three
third-party vendors that have also
developed quality control
materials and i've just summarized some
of their key
characteristics of those products here
so for all three
major vendors the the source is a human
sourced plasma or
serum that's in a liquid ready to use
format
so you don't need to rehydrate which is
nice the shelf life for these products
is generally pretty long
at least one year if unopened and then
ranging anywhere from 10 to 30 days
after opening and i should mention that
bio rad is working on extending that
open expiration date out to about 60
days
and this open expiration date is
important from a workflow perspective
because unlike for molecular tests where
controls are taken out
and typically thawed right before the
run is started for many of these high
throughput assays
the controls are loaded and kind of left
on the instrument
until they're used up or they expire so
you can also see what antibody isotypes
these controls are designed
to detect with currently none of them
actually have an igm specific control
reagent that's available and then i've
also included what type of assay these
vendors are using to
qc their controls before they're before
they're released
so you can see that technopath and bio
bio-rad qc their
control material using both the
nucleocapsid and a spike-based
antibody assay whereas circare at least
from what i can tell is only using a
nucleocapsid-based
assay to qc their material
so although one would expect or envision
that both anti-spike and anti-nuclear
capsid
antibodies are present that may not
always be the case
and so this is just something to keep in
mind
if things look kind of wonky if you will
during the verification
of this control for a spike based assay
and then also while a target range for
these controls
is not indicated or really defined
ceracare does state that they intend
their
positive control to be a low positive
for these assays
although you can imagine that this is
probably going to vary
from assay to assay so
for tests without an in-kit
control there are a number of general
factors to consider
when selecting the control material and
one of the
most important considerations is the
type
of control material you're going to use
so ideally that control should be
different than the calibrator that's
used in the assay
but if there are no other options
available the lab could validate control
material but it would have to be pulled
from a different
kit lot than the one that's currently in
use
thankfully for stars cov2 there are a
number of
options available for alternative
control material
so as i mentioned earlier assay vendors
do offer their own
controls which is nice but these
controls are often really
optimized for the assay and they may be
similar in formulation to their
calibrator
so as a result use of these may not as
readily detect potential performance
issues
so there's these third-party vended
controls on the other hand which are not
typically
designed with any specific assay in mind
so they're independent they're an
independent check
of assay performance characteristics and
are often
preferred from a quality assurance
quality management
perspective and then finally another
approach is for labs to validate
and use pooled patient samples for
control material
which while less expensive as dr newton
mentioned there's a number of
challenges here they're often related to
stability issues having sufficient
specimen volume depending on the
prevalence of the analyte
there could be issues with result
consistency
and so on so other general
considerations
to think about when choosing a control
include making sure that the material
you choose matches the assay you're
using
it's probably an obvious point but it's
an important one as this has been
overlooked
a couple of times in my experience you
also want to strive to use control
material
in a matrix as close to possible to the
patient samples that you're testing
ideally that material would be available
in large batch sizes to minimize the
variability and then allow
for trending over long periods of time
over different kit lots
and so that goes along with the
preference that these materials have a
relatively long
shelf life and then obviously cost is
something that
most labs will consider as well
so once a control material is selected
a few common questions typically come up
including how frequently
should qcb run so per the cap immunology
checklist for non-waived tests
controls should be run at least daily
which is also what
most vendors recommend but they can
obviously be run more frequently and
that's typically a call that's made by
the laboratory director themselves
so the frequency of control testing is
to an extent dependent on the method
that's used so for batch testing where
there is a defined start and stop time
during which all the calibrator control
and patient measurements
occur qc is run with each each batch and
so that's typically
the case for your elisa-based assays on
the other hand
for methods that allow for continuous
load or
continuous testing there's really not
a similar kind of defined time interval
during which all these measurements
occur
testing just goes on until reagents need
to be replenished or there's instrument
instrument maintenance or the instrument
is shut down for whatever reason
and again most manufacturers still
recommend qc testing
just every 24 hours so there's a number
of potential issues
with this fairly infrequent control
schedule
including the need to do quite an
extensive look back if that control
fails
and so for that reason many labs run
controls much more frequently so for
example we
run them about every eight hours or so
and this type of qc is often referred to
as bracketed qc
because if the qc passes one can assume
that the patient measurements
that were made between the two qc events
or brackets
are um are likely acceptable
and then in general qc should be run
whenever there's any sort of scheduled
events that could change the performance
of the assay including things like
calibrations or maintenance
or new lot or new killer calibrator lots
and in those situations it's actually
recommended that qc be performed
both before the change to ensure that
samples tested up until that point are
valid
and then also after the event to confirm
that that change
did not impact or alter assay
performance
so another common question that comes up
is
whether the numerical or quantitative
value of the control
matters for qualitative serologic tests
in particular
especially since we're just reporting
positive or negative results
so as a quick refresher the current high
throughput serologic assays are designed
such that qualitative results are
determined
based on an established signal to cut
off or index value
threshold and so anything above or below
that threshold is resulted as positive
or negative respectively
and so for such tests clsi recommends
that at least two control levels be used
one above
and one below that threshold and then
ideally that positive control level
should be near that qualitative cutoff
or qualitative threshold since at that
level
the control is much more likely to
detect an out of control situation
compared to a positive control which
with a much higher
relative level of that analyte so
choosing
what that control level is or can be can
be tricky though because you don't want
it to be too close or at that cut off
threshold since that might lead to
control failures and unnecessary
rejection of runs
so to overcome this we typically
consider the assay precision
characteristics that we've established
during the verification and then choose
a control level
that's about two to three fold above
that cut off threshold
and then i also just wanted to mention
that along these lines the cap
immunology checklist has a requirements
uh specifically stating that that
qualitative cutoff threshold needs to be
verified initially
after implementation and then every six
months thereafter
um and depending on the assay while some
have
calibrators that are either near or used
to determine that threshold
another way to satisfy this requirement
is to use
controls that are near that near that
cutoff
so when it comes to establishing the
control material
target value and range there's a couple
of things to keep in mind
first you know while some vendors may
provide already
pre-assigned values and ranges for their
controls
those should really be used as more of a
guide and not a replacement for
individual
laboratory established control means and
ranges
and then there are a couple of ways to
determine the means and ranges
associated with these controls depending
on
whether or not the laboratory has
historical data
available for those particular qc
materials
so for example since the imprecision of
an
assay is an innate characteristic of the
test
regardless of the quality control
material
if there is historic qc data available
for that control
and that control has performed well
without issues in the past
the established sd or standard deviation
can be applied
to the new qc material if that target
level is similar between the two lots
so the mean of the new qc lot can be
determined using 10 measurements
ideally on separate days and then you
can apply that historic sd value around
the new mean
in most cases though especially for
sarsko v2 controls there's
no historic qc data available because
these products are just so
new so in that case new control means
and sd values have to be established
prior to
implementation of the control material
and as a standard this is usually
established
by measuring 10 uh 10 points
ideally those are acquired on separate
days
to account for as much variability as
possible and then these 20 points can be
plotted on a levy jennings chart to look
for any drifts or shifts or outliers
and if none are observed all of those
points can be used to establish the mean
and sd of that control material and so
this is just an example
of what our 20 points look like for the
saracare positive control material
that was run on the orthoclinical igg
chemiluminescent
assay and then oftentimes because of the
potential limited reliability of
the initially established sd values
we'll
often reevaluate the mean and sd about
one to two months into running the
controls this really allows us to take
into account
additional procedural procedural
variations
and factors like use of different
calibrators different reagent lots
any preventative maintenance and so on
so we have a much larger
data set with which to work with that
would lead to a more realistic
and a more accurate sd
and then finally you'll obviously want
to monitor your qc values over time
often again using levy jennings charts
and applying
the various westgard rules including
ideally use of both single event qc
rules which will detect kind of large
shifts in the assay
or or i should say and using
counting qc rules which will detect
smaller shifts or trends in the assay
over time
so for for example in our lab we
routinely look at 1 3 s 2 2
s and 4 1 s failures or trends for
for our tests and so that leads me
into a very brief kind of case study
that involved a control for one of our
stars kobe 2 serologic tests again
kind of underscoring the importance of
monitoring qc over time
so um we implemented a third party qc
material for our total antibody sars
cody2 assay
and after about a month we noticed that
the signal to cutoff ratio for that
positive control material was trending
uh downward on all of our kobas e 801
instruments and you can
you can see kind of a bird's eye view of
that in these charts
so we performed an investigation to see
what was going on and found that
for the most part the negative control
signal to cut off levels remained
uh remains stable we also retested
previously positive patient samples and
found that those signal to cutoff values
were stable and
within the expected imprecision of the
assay
and then also prior to implementation of
the vended
control material we were using pooled
positive and negative
patient controls and so we pulled those
out of the freezer
and tested those and similarly found
that the signal to cut off
ratios remained within the expected
range so
our conclusion was ultimately that we
were probably seeing
some sort of degradation of our positive
control material
despite it still being within with
instability
and i will note that this was not the
bio red control but we ultimately moved
to
using an alternative vended third party
control
um but again this is just one example of
why you'd want to monitor the numerical
values of your controls even if the
results you're reporting are simply
qualitative because
as you can imagine over time this would
lead to failed runs and lots of
unnecessary look backs and investigation
so to conclude just some general
suggestions for
antibody related quality control
third-party vendor
control material is often preferred
similar to
the situation for other assays in order
to kind of independently monitor
the performance of your of your tests
for qualitative assays which are based
off of a cut off threshold you
again need two levels of control with
the positive one ideally being
near that qualitative thrush threshold
and you'll want to establish and verify
your own control ranges
the frequency of control testing will be
dependent
on the method you use as well as the
laboratory workflow but it's typically
more frequent than
the uh just once for 24 hours
and then finally just remember the
importance of monitoring
your qc for trending over time in order
to avoid
potentially unnecessary assay
control failures and so with that
i will thank you for your attention and
turn it back to susie
and thank you dr thiel for that great
presentation
we will now start the q and a portion of
the webinar
if you have any questions you want to
ask to either dr
newton or dr thiel please do so now just
click
on that ask a question box located on
the far
left of your screen so let's get started
our first question is for you dr newton
what is the purpose of including genomic
human dna in stars cov2 control
thanks susie it's a really good question
and
the there are a variety of assays that
are available including
the original cdc sars kov2 assay
that use human targets as internal
controls for their assay
so those target genes like the
rnasp gene are present in that genomic
material
and so those would be present in a
clinical specimen
and so for our external controls or any
kick controls that have genomic material
in it they would be able to detect those
targets as well i think it also has
alluded to
in my description of ideal an ideal
control material because of that genomic
material would be present in a clinical
specimen
having it part of a control would
really help to ensure that that control
mimics
what a real patient specimen would look
like
our next question is for both of you as
long as my positive
qc is positive and negative is negative
why would i worry about shifts or trends
for a qualitative test we'll start with
you dr phil
uh right so it's a great great question
because at face value right we report
positive or negative and if our controls
are positive or negative correctly then
everything should be fine right
unfortunately just a qual pause negative
doesn't really tell you much about the
analytical performance of your assay so
as in
the example case i showed earlier i
think really shows that so
technically the controls we had
qualitatively were in
they passed but clearly something was
going on
and if we didn't monitor those
quantitative values i think at some
point we
we would have reached a point where our
positive control
would have repeatedly tested negative
and we'd have to do
quite a bit of kind of backtracking and
investigation
and failing runs unnecessarily so for
that reason i think even for qualitative
tests it's helpful to
monitor those numeric values
and even if they're not necessarily
clinically significant
thank you so much dr phil and how about
you dr newton
i agree with what dr thiel said
and would just add to that you know in
her case description
she described um degradation of the
product as one
as the reason why that um those trends
went down
there are a lot of situations that could
happen
that um would impact the performance of
that material and
it really highlights not only the value
of looking at
the numbers but to actually have that
external control
as part of your assay that's carried out
over
many many lots over many many days of
you know
and even uh potentially across many
different instruments that you'd have
something that you can compare
compared to not just in a positive or
negative way but in a
purely quantitative way um to
to evaluate when those issues are or to
identify when those issues
um are coming up and so
the those those numbers as as dr thiel
said are really important because
without that you don't you don't see
that information
you don't see that change as
dramatically and as uh
obviously thank you so much
our next question is for you dr thiel is
there any guidance
available suggesting which targets are
preferred
for antibody testing i mean in terms of
nucleus kept said s1 s2
or receptor binding domains and if not
do you have any
recommendations yeah so that's a
a good question so there's
many studies now coming out right
looking at our immune response to these
various sarcove-2 proteins and
antigens but kind of at a high level
i think there's a few take home points
that we can take from those so overall
i don't actually think there's a really
meaningful difference in sensitivity
especially during the early stages of
infection between
using serologic assays that are based on
the nucleic acid
protein versus any of the spike
based protein assays you know regardless
of the test
all individuals seroconvert or not all
most
zero convert 12 to 14 days after symptom
onset
um from a longevity perspective i think
we'll we're still really learning about
how long these antibodies last
it's you know especially to the various
proteins
there's some recent studies suggesting
that maybe antibodies to the
nucleocapsid
decline faster than those to the spike
proteins but honestly i think the jury
is still out on that
and then even though it's kind of hard
to say exactly what will happen
in the future and what will be needed
once we have vaccines available
many of the vaccines are you know kind
of
a targeting or trying to stimulate an
immune response to the spike protein
in particular so it may be beneficial to
have spike based assays
on board but again how those will be
used in the future is hard to say
thank you so much dr thiel our next
question is for you dr newton
what's the best material to evaluate the
limit of detection
for my method
yeah the thing the um important thing to
recognize first is that different assays
have ultimately will have different
limits of detection
so if you have multiple platforms in
your lab that you're evaluating
you need to have a material that has
a is present in a
high concentration a high enough
concentration where you can make a wide
range of dilutions that allow you to
really
really differentiate those lods from
assay to assay
and as i mentioned in the talk you know
some of the
some of the controls that are available
from commercial manufacturers don't
don't come in high enough concentration
to allow you to make
broad dilution series especially
and when you make those dilutions you're
going to spike them into
transport media a mill or three mils of
transport media which further dilutes
the sample and and so the concentration
of that
dilution needs to be very high when you
when you're spiking it
and so that i think is the first thing
the second thing that's really important
is that the concentration of the
material is really accurate
and so there are a variety of
options that are out there that have
used droplet digital pcr
to quantify that material and the
and those numbers are are very very
accurate
and very very precise so i think those
are the
the two most important factors that
allow you to have
high concentrations that are accurately
represented
and then that finally that it's a
material
that can be stable over time that you
can
make dilutions store them and pull them
out
and test them again and get the same
get the same results because you're
often
doing these experiments on multiple days
with multiple
individuals and multiple instruments and
you'd like
to have the solutions that you're using
to make that determination be the same
in all those evaluations you're not
going back and
and repeating and adding another very
variable process
thank you so much dr newton and i want
to thank our audience for these great
questions coming in
we have time for just one more question
and it goes to you dr
seal some third-party qc vendors
provide inter-laboratory comparison
reports for their qc
are there any benefits from
participating in such a program for sars
co-lead to antibody testing
sure so there are definitely some
benefits to participating in programs
like that
because it does in some cases provide
kind of a real-time
intra-laboratory comparison or an
evaluation of how your
your controls are performing and
ultimately how your assay is
is performing so these sorts of programs
basically let the lab
see how they their assay is performing
leverage
relative to other laboratories using the
same assets and
controls um and if you find that your
controls are kind of blocking
compared to other athletes you'll be
able to see that
issue fairly quickly and take
appropriate measures to investigate the
issue before
before it becomes a major problem so
thank you so much dr dr thiel thank you
both for your time
today and for your important work and
your research before we go
i do want to thank the audience again
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions
and questions we did not have time to
address today will be answered and
posted in that event
resources by the end of next week this
webcast will be available
on demand in the auditorium from friday
on and if you found this
information informative and helpful
please share it with your colleagues
bio rad will be hosting a new qc related
webinar
every month this year next month's topic
is
how to limit patient harm from erroneous
results qc strategies based on risk
management and will be held in september
on september 16th please check back
regularly for new topics
and take time to explore our posters
booths and bio rads new covid
product showcase in the virtual
conference until next time
take care be safe and bye